great so you know how to chop up a
webpage design into boxes and you've
even heard advice from an experienced
front-end developer let's take a look at
another very simple example how do you
transfer this to an HTML document and
how do you change how the boxes look let
me quickly show you how to translate the
model to HTML and then you will write it
in a file that you can open in your
browser in this design you can see that
there are four boxes we have one over
the title another over this content and
then two more boxes inside of this
larger box one around the image and
another around the text so let's not
worry about how these boxes look or
what's inside of them and let's not
worry that I haven't actually perfectly
aligned the top of this box with that
one it's driving me crazy but we don't
have to worry about it right now now you
can define this type of box with a div
tag we'll write this code using sublime
text and we suggest that you use either
this code editor or something similar
now we define boxes with div tags so
let's go ahead and create tags for each
of our boxes first we'll start with the
title box and start typing div now this
is the really nice thing of using a code
editor like sublime text it
automatically is guessing what we might
use so we do know we want it to be a div
we can click tab and now we have the
completed HTML tags an opening tag and a
closing tag next we have another box for
the content which requires another div
tag and now within this box we have two
more boxes so we'll hit another line so
now we have four div tags for our four
boxes now let's add some placeholder
content so that we remember which boxes
each of our tags refer to so our first
one is for our title which is my app and
then we have our image and our text now
that's great but how do you apply style
to them the boxes are of different sizes
and they're in different locations and
you
- somehow mark them so that you can
easily apply style later now the best
way to do this is to give each element a
class attribute now you can think of
these class attributes as labels on
boxes something that reminds you of
what's inside of them for example when
you move you might give a box a label to
let the movers know where it might go
for example master bedroom or kitchen
now boxes can also have several labels
and the same applies to HTML tags they
can belong to multiple classes now back
to our moving example you might want to
say the items that go to the kitchen are
also fragile so you might add handle
with care
it's a good idea to have class names
that make sense so that you understand
what the purpose of the box is just by
glancing at the code for example while
you could just give the divs class names
like box 1 box 2 etc it's not really
informative I mean will you really
remember that you call this title box
box 1 probably not what would make more
sense is to name the top div title and
then the bottom big div app then the div
that contains the application image
screenshot and the text 1 description
excellent we now have the general
structure of the page down so now it's
your turn to save this in a file and see
how it looks in the browser instructions
for doing so follow